[Music]
sure ariana grande might be an
international pop star now but back in
the day she was just a little girl
working hard to make it big so no matter
what i'm grateful on thursday night the
28 year old's thank you next singer
appeared on the tonight show starring
jimmy fallon and jimmy he surprised ari
with footage of her first singing gig
when she was just eight years old
belting out the national anthem at a
florida panthers hockey game oh my gosh
are we going here yes that was that was
my first gig
[Music]
pretty cute right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
seems pretty clear that ari wanted to be
in the industry for a long time in fact
she told a story about colds calling
nickelodeon when she was just four years
old i have this weird
manifesting gift i think when i was four
years old i um caught i did 4-1-1 i got
through somehow like by some miracle i
got through and they were like hey
universal studios orlando and i said um
hi i would like to audition to be on all
that or the amanda show your pick you
tell me
you guys you got something it's a few
but i would love to be on either or your
pick and um
and they were like
how old are you and i was like don't
worry about it and while they might have
hung up on ari at the time she went on
to get her big break on that exact
network in 2010 on the show victorious
[Music]
of course the whole singing thing worked
out for ari too not only is she a
multi-platinum selling superstar she's
also now a coach on the voice i was a
huge fan of the voice i have watched
many seasons i've always been a fan and
i feel so grateful to be here and she
just landed the role of glinda in the
feature film adaptation of the broadway
play wicked i'm happy life is good and
that whole thing already said about
being good at manifesting i have this
weird
manifesting gift i think she wasn't
kidding back in 2011 she tweeted about
seeing the show on broadway writing
quote loved seeing wicked again amazing
production made me realize again how
badly i want to play glinda at some
point in my life hashtag dream roll well
done we can't wait to watch you fly high
and defy gravity
[Music]
you